so we need to do is just sit still and
relax first couple of minutes breathe
freely don't hold your breath
wired to probes that monitor his heart
and temperature Lewis Pugh is about to
find out whether the months of training
that he's done for his epic swim have
paid off
first up the dunk test for Coldwater
shock it's 18 degrees the same
temperature as the English Channel but
Lewis doesn't even in fact is you'll
know your heart rate is now 92 which is
exactly what it was that's a classic
response or somebody who's called a
[ __ ] rated then a tougher test buff
hypothermia is 350 miles swimming from
corner to Kent swimming spending up to
six hours a day in the water
the results are reassuring the fat he's
put on insulates him against the cold
but it will still be a grueling swim day
after day the critical aspect is what
happens in the hour or two after he
leaves the water
preparing him for the next room getting
in physically physiologically and
psychologically ready to go again
analysis of the air that Luis breeds out
shows he'll burn up to 10,000 calories a
day energy you'll need to replace by
vastly increasing his food intake
it is his toughest ever swim but they
can't capture here is suddenly now when
you're fighting against a tide or a
current and maybe there's an eddy and
it's pushing you backwards and now
you're arguing with the pilot you know
where should you be swimming and now
suddenly in a huge bloom of jellyfish or
now you're in a really strong easterly
wind and all these things and piling on
okay this isn't just a physical
challenge it's a mental one - for
several hours a day Luis is going to be
on his own in the water staring at
nothing but the gloom of the English
Channel cut off from his support team
Victoria Cox swam from England to France
last year she says swimming the length
of the channel will require
extraordinary mental fortitude by the
end of a channel swim you cut you can
it's actually difficult to swallow you
can't taste anything your tongue is
swollen in your mouth and even even
basic things like eating and drinking
are actually really difficult and quite
painful as well body fat you can measure
grit you can't Luis will need both for
what he calls the Everest of swims Tomas
more Sky News Portsmouth